welcome to this video playing then
international marseille from germany is
always playing those g6 setups king's
indian and simula play the h3 line let's
see what is coming up with age successor
normally move that white likes to see in
the scattered position 92 is some a
prophylactic on move yeah we're getting
a sort of benoni now we are like screen
as a bit strangely placed of course he
can correct correct this just clean dat
ya both captures are good I think okay
and I always like to attack with the
upon because the Cirque and of structure
really gives them very little counter
play to black so should I play I think I
should
Bishop f4 to attack the pawn now first
improve my position a bit more
b5 not sure that's
let's play some the pieces some more
ammonia sway the bishop of one okay how
to continue now sb5 a threat maybe maybe
he can do that at the end at the end
time d 5 episode is a bit weak maybe
push everyone wasn't so great now that
I'm think of it mmm now it was too slow
quindi item was a move that is some
useful anyway okay someone got nothing
great iam
mmm yeah don't really have a great plan
in this position but some my pieces are
not are not placed placed very well
maybe night you form is something that
improves my position putting some
pressure on d6
yeah this Lucas super annoying you to
get rid of that okay so we have a
simplified position now at f5 is so
really strange why are five and just
weaken some blacks position considerably
I don't think you had any substantial
problems before that check
now I'm just invading on the light
squares got H form as an additional IDM
and bishops III of course okay let's
start with age for
yeah I don't intend to treat Queen sir I
think this would help him
Bishop f5 another another idea to
threaten not threaten mate yeah it's I'm
not easy to cover that check check and
that's it black resigned yeah he
completely self destructed with f5
completely unnecessary move if you place
anything normal it should be four or
something there's nothing happening or
let's say I don't know Queenie seven any
nothing move but f5 I mean maybe you
stand can't stand that but it's already
tricky but after g5 it's it's it's
straight away down the drain yeah I
hadn't hadn't played this really well
starting starting here Bishop Bishop f1
was awesome animals I'm not quite sure
what what I should do but wish everyone
didn't help at all because Quinn d8 is
useful anyway ah I don't know maybe
Bishop f4 something like that and now
something else you have I briefly
thought about this move trying to
prevent be five but it looks really
clumsy opposite the rook yeah difficult
benoni structures are always tense and
somewhat difficult to assess okay thanks
for watching